jean roba ya un grand sac c'est pour un
goûter de famille
écoute je suis désolé casimir mais il me
reste plus que quelques dragées au
poivre
c'est tout mais c'est très embêtant un
maniaque tante adélaïde va être furieuse
elle organise un goûter pour
l'anniversaire de son poisson rouge
je n'ai jamais vu manger des dragées au
poivre au poisson non les poissons dont
mes cousins adore ça et je ne peux pas
arriver les mains vides
il faut que j'amène un petit cadeau pour
tout le monde sinon ma tante adélaïde la
guerre corps cause le manque de savoir
vivre
c'était pas si dramatique que sa cabine
s'il pense que quand ma tante adélaïde
de nous faire rentrer quelque chose dans
la tête elle prend une grosse poche il
nous tape sur la tête mais c'est une
véritable brut ta tante adélaïde
n'auront pas du tout elle dit simplement
que les zones casimir husson la tête un
peu durer que quelques coupes du ch
n'ont jamais fait de mal à personne
je crois que c'est un traitement qui
doit être réservé exclusivement aux
casimir us
peut-être peut-être mais enfin je ne
peux pas arriver avec seulement quatre
ou cinq dragées sinon je veux voir où
coups de bûche mois à temps dans mon
rayon des farces et attrapes c'était
quelque chose en revient au gardien
partout on pouvait faire un mélange ou
si ça j'ai des caramels au poivre des
caramels au point où j'adore ça tu peux
pas m'en venais quelques-uns coups de
suite à non casimiri faut tout gardé
pour ta tante adélaïde si tu veux faire
preuve de savoir vivre et ne pas
recevoir d'un coup de bûche cionet un
joli juste un tout petit nom casimir
soit résolue au générateur toujours
pareil il faut toujours que je sois sage
oiseaux nabeul tu veux faire plaisir à
ta tante adélaïde et ato casimiro bien
sûr je veux donc à loris tu peut pas
manger ce que tu vas leur offrir
alors tu as raison en bois d'accord mais
met tout dans sa captivité
tu vois que d'élire ce n'est pas si
difficile que ça d'être raisonnable il
suffit de faire de vouloir faire plaisir
à ceux qu'on aime c'est tout bon alors
je suis
souvent étrangers raisonnable bien sûr
ou 10 mois
j'ai encore quelques chocolats au coton
ça t'intéresse c'est un peu spécial
enfin amélie quand même j'ai des cousins
bien d'autres bon ben je crois que c'est
tout ce que je jeu qui peut t'intéresser
bon ça fait un bon paquet c'est pas mal
ça suffira comme sainte croix bon dit
moi je dis combien ce que je te dois
calculons et un franc de dragées au
poivre
en plus deux fronts de caramel aux
faïences a fait qu'on la france plus un
front de chocolat ou coûteux ça fait 4
offrant quatre favoris juste le nombre
de doigts de la main d'un casimir us si
cela valait bien d'accord bon écoute of
the givers la zone des pêcheurs est-ce
que je suis beau on puisse super pas bon
tu sais je crois qu'un bon cadeau va
faire beaucoup d'effet j'en suis sûr
amuse-toi bien aller à demain julie de
l'ain casimir mais julie mais les dunes
est pas encore prête ou non mais tu es
vraiment chic
je te remercie bonjour merci julie mais
didot au toit du freudienne que des
péchés elle va muer des péchés mais
pourquoi pourquoi mais mais julie mais
nous allons en grand goûter offert par
la tante adélaïde mais je n'étais pas au
courant
comment tu étais pas en cours il faut
souligner mais je t'ai poser
l'invitation sur tokyo ce maintien
la voilà julie il faut que tu pourras
voir un petit peu d'ordre bossi cas
l'idée d'aller mettre des invitations
soul et beaucoup de boue
oui j'ai dit ce n'est vraiment pas le
moment de nous disputer nous sommes déjà
si en retard comme ça je t'assure
n'était que je dois l'avouer mais faut
que je me change mois habitué très bien
comme ça tu es parfait tu crois qu'ils
aillent vite au costes vite jeté des
mecs plus dépêche
mais ce n était pas un un goûter casimir
us que c'est nous et nous il ya le ya le
facteur ya il ya monsieur bush a
maintenu son hub lolette et casimir de
caisse qui l'a quasiment cellaouate
casino c'est bien ce que je craignais
public et vous tous les deux au meilleur
j'ai des coups de bûche de sa tante
adélaïde sur la tête
ouais il est raconté moi pourquoi et je
suis allé au goûter organisé par ma
tante adélaïde ah oui j'ai emporté un
grand sac de bonbons
seuls les a aussitôt distribué à ses
invités d'eau alors que nrj et alors
mais alors le facteur a pris un caramel
aux poires monsieur du snav a pris au
chocolat fourré au couteau et monsieur
mohsen une dragées au poivre
ar alors ma tante adélaïde a pris sa
plus grosse bûche et hop voilà enfin
[Musique]